uh every chocolate goes great with red
wine doesn't it sherry
i think it does but you know what i like
better oh man
i like banana and peanut butter
sandwiches
[Laughter]
are way too good
all right so i'm going to boogie to the
trick-or-treat forecast today
all right see where you all should go
down my face
i'm not letting nate talk about my mummy
today
i'm bad about my mummy
all right we got a great trick-or-treat
forecast guys we're going to be down to
79.
it is super super mild on saturday we're
looking at 82 for a high mid 70s by 7
o'clock
i think the kids are gonna love
trick-or-treating if you're taking them
out
maybe you will maybe you won't whatever
moves you
all right we've got a beautiful early
sky out there sun won't be up until a
few minutes after
seven lots of 50s super mild this
morning nellis you found 49 degrees
about the only neighborhood
in the valley outside the valley though
it's been a little bit cooler 44 in
perum
50 in mesquite 47 at red rock this
weekend
we're going to get even milder check
this out so for halloween this year
82 degrees remember last year it was a
chilly one
61 for the daytime high so we could
either be
extra warm or extra chilly if you've
lived here for a while you know that a
lot of times the really cold
air blows in right around halloween but
not this year
we fall back to standard time saturday
night and sunday morning so don't forget
those clocks
and look at election day tuesday 84
degrees we'll keep those near
record highs through the first week of
november all right let's get to the road
so 6 49
are they boogieing down the road just
fine they sure are sheri when i first
saw your little costume there i had a
suspicious mind
yeah i'm sure